everybody have fun tonight everybody
have fun sup [ __ ] welcome to another
episode of genius brain podcast I'm your
host David so with my co-host George
it's cowboy baby dude I remember the
first time I actually learned of your
last name you know what the funny thing
is did you I don't understand what
people didn't know you were John oh
right you japanese [ __ ] face on dude
you look like an anime character it's
because you knew japanese people growing
up growing up a lot of people they don't
know they just don't know they thought I
was binamis they thought I was Chinese
not like Korean like he's Vietnamese I
was like he does not have a [ __ ]
Vietnamese face to save his life his
[ __ ] is Japanese as [ __ ]
you had like the prominent Japanese nose
you have the thick Japanese hair the
facial hairs Japanese I was like this
happen ease teeth the beautiful Japanese
crooked teeth like what the [ __ ] so like
I remember um like you guys couldn't
tell me you guys his ethnicity the
person I couldn't figure out was
obviously Bart yeah Bart was just he
just looked Karina's [ __ ] me yeah
yeah yeah you know let's have a Korean
face the Korean tattoo and everything
and I was like wait I don't understand
what's going on with this guy so he was
a mystery but you were Japanese as hell
dude
when I was in Seoul I took a selfie with
a with the soldier out there because
that fool look like Bart's brother yeah
like they both look so alike I was like
I gotta get a selfie with this dude he
looks Korean as [ __ ] yeah so when he
told me that he was Chinese that blew my
[ __ ] mind dude I was like I thought
you were Korean dude well he's like he's
like part native cuz a he has Peruvian
but I was like 10% or something yeah and
he has like Chinese and all kinds of
different Chinese but he grew up with so
many Korean yeah he knew so much Korean
inside jokes that's something that only
Korea people wouldn't write so that [ __ ]
threw me off my god Lee but you're
[ __ ] Japanese as hell man and then it
was your cousin dude yeah so he's such a
freaking angel man so we were we were
going on a hike and Joe just to preface
with the story he told his cousin not to
say anything about his ethnicity because
nobody knew at the time yeah I didn't
even know I knew what geo was
I didn't know what Bart or Joe was yeah
and so we were trying to keep it under
wraps and then as we were hiking she
goes oh so how long have you been
friends with my sceptic good that's like
I was in the car with Geo and I was like
flipping through pictures and I just go
huh Gio's eyes go BOOM wide she goes oh
man she is so funny it's like it's like
you know when you when you tell your mom
like hey this is a secret and she's like
all right and then she'll tell her
friend the secret but she won't change
her voice tone she'll just cover her
mouth and be like did you hear yeah did
you hear that he had his first kiss yeah
that's that's basically what my cousin
was doing it's like man you are not
discreet dude that [ __ ] was so fun and
in her mind she goes I didn't tell him
yeah but you said Masato that's a
[ __ ] Japanese yeah funny dying man
but wasn't gonna be freaking Zimbabwe
yeah like but you know who actually
somebody told me earlier but they didn't
I didn't understand where the reference
was coming from you know Tom right yeah
he goes do you know Joe's like actual
real last name and I was like no I don't
know what it is he goes it's like mama
Joe mama and I was like his last name is
mom yeah what do you mean MoMA yeah but
he didn't know that yeah he was like cuz
I guess one time when you guys were
going out to eat he saw your card and he
saw I said mama and that's how he said
it to me he goes his last name is mama
that's like what the [ __ ] ethnicity is
that you jackass like my doesn't help me
out yeah mama he goes his name is Joe
mama yeah no that can't be it did this
that's not of any ethnic Asian variety
and alright but it was MoMA yeah because
my my dad when he came to the states you
know through immigration and all that
[ __ ] they're like what's your name and
you said mama and then they said okay
and then they spelled they wrote down
mama oh okay that way he was supposed to
write down M Oh N ma ma ma yeah would it
make more sense right but then that's
that's what they wrote so it just stick
is just it just stuck
yeah like jomama yeah I did I did [ __ ]
no mama no mama yep it's okay people
call me fatso so it's all good that's
actually genius you little [ __ ] but
yeah I mean that was that was a my
parent my dad's last name but then after
you know him and my mom split
I took my grandma's name mmm but the
funny thing is my grandma's maiden name
is Ito oh yeah so you took the the mate
name that she got married into and she
had a divorce and I didn't know that she
didn't change her last name she didn't
change it
oh I should keep it she was too lazy oh
this is so interesting but you know what
though I think she she loves my grandpa
because it wasn't it wasn't bad because
when she had Alzheimer's she would
always talk about him
she's like oh you know my husband like
and then she she's like yeah he's gonna
come home and like so I think she I
think at the end of the day what I what
I'm just as long as she loved him yeah
he's still my grandpa I never met the
dude because he passed when I was born
so it's like cool I'm carrying on a name
of someone she cares about why did they
split well funny story is um okay so
like in Japan like both of my families
came from a pretty high pedigree like
like my grandma you know her her father
was executive at the Toshiba Corporation
oh [ __ ] dude you're royalty what the
[ __ ] well dude get this like the
chaperone that basically yeah yeah so
she had an arranged marriage and then
the person that she married which was my
grandpa yeah mmm like he you know the
the person that basically was their
chaperone was a he's he's like the
Hitler of Japan but his name was Tojo
yeah Admiral Tojo and then so like back
in the day when you have an arranged
marriage a male and female can't go on a
date alone yeah you have to have
somebody there watching the whole thing
and also they're kind of there to like
report to the parents and we like yeah I
think you know they like each other or
like they're kind of like if they're
also like young they don't they're too
shy and they don't know how to start a
conversation
so they
director conversation to the dude and
he's like the Icebreaker so he's the
third wheel yeah so my grandma had that
dude like as her chaperone and she had
no idea of what kind of a like sinister
dude he was she had no [ __ ] clue and
and also like a lot of things was weird
to me because the way that she talked
about the war was not like how my
friends
grandma's talked about the war well so
basically she was like I was like do you
remember the bombings and goes yeah one
time like they bombed our estate and in
all of us in the in the in the maids had
to get the fire off the the roof and
we're like us in the maids what the [ __ ]
right and then she goes yeah it was so
bad that we had to go to our country
home to like hi I'm like what like I was
like wait so during the war they had
another home that was in the countryside
and in her and her like my family there
they had to just hang out there but
we're talking about grave of the
fireflies everyone in Japan is starving
she still had food she was like moving
from house the house so so so that was
that was her part of the life early on
right and so she gets married to my my
grandpa who was an accountant and he
came from a prestigious family too and
so the problem that happened was he kind
of got stuck without like he got he got
into a bad habit with alcohol yeah and
my mom has fond memories of him she was
like he was never abusive like he drank
a lot he was drunk but he was like a
happy drunk she didn't hear them argue
but then he was always out working and
then she was she says that I just
remember him being drunk all the time
yeah and then so he had a problem with
alcohol he was never sober but he was
like a party animal and what my grandma
told my mom like all of us when we got
older was he was just constantly
partying getting hookers and like they
had for years
yeah they had three or four properties
under their name all of them just
gambled away so he had a gambling
addiction and so my grandma was so
pissed
that she was like I can't raise my
children under this type of environment
yeah
and back then like divorce was a huge
[ __ ] deal
of course you don't do especially in
prestigious families if you divorce
that's like sustain right it makes the
whole family look back on the ITO name
yeah but my grandma's uh um she's kind
of a renegade like she was the first one
of the first few women in her generation
to actually go to a college and
university yeah so like back then like
women just didn't do that kind of [ __ ]
yeah so well she didn't have to either
right because she was already born into
wealth right but she's smart
so she loved debating she loved like
thinking she's a troublemaker day so
because of that she went to university
despite her parents wishes not to tour
like why don't you just find a good
husband she's like [ __ ] that right yeah
so she went to university she did all
this stuff and then that was a tough
time too because a lot of guys were
intimidated by that yeah so then of
course yeah so she she couldn't get
married but then her sister which was
like she was pretty so my my my don't
know would you say great aunt or
whatever my grandma's sister she was
pretty she was taller she was always
like done up really well she's like your
typical classy woman my grandma my on
the other hand look at our old pictures
she was a straight-up tomboy like she's
her hair's all [ __ ] up but anyways
like so yeah she finally got married all
this stuff happened and then the divorce
happened and then like back then to give
you an idea of how bad divorce is like
technically you're not supposed to allow
your daughter home if she had a divorce
she has to be off on her oh it's like
you have to shun your dog it's bad man
like to give you an idea how bad it is
so my cut Mike my uncle he he was broke
as [ __ ] right yeah and his mom was in an
abusive relationship so so he would beat
the [ __ ] out of the kids beat the [ __ ]
out of his mom like her all that stuff
so when his mom begged her father to
take her back you
because you know he's like my husband's
beating me like I need to get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah he said I can't because
it's gonna ruin the family name and he
goes if I bring you back into my home
that it's like you failed you has a
woman you fail that's what he told her
right so her she she had three kids
uh-huh my uncle's the youngest one night
she grabbed my she took my uncle and
then like basically ran away and she was
living in like a barn like she just
basically broke into a barn and like
lived throughout the winter and all that
and the farmer found her and they're
just like well I guess you could stay
yeah and that's that's what they had to
do but so but my grandma when she had a
divorce and she went back to my grandpa
I mean great-grandpa what he ended up
doing was at the edge of their property
at well they had this huge estate they
just built her a house they just
literally just built her a house just so
she could live there with my with my mom
and my aunt oh wow so he's like well I
can't take you back in but I'll just
built you build you a separate house so
you could be close to me down the block
yeah and then you can you can live there
and then so like it's almost better yeah
but I mean it's it's a different it's
it's just crazy like like I'm just like
wow that's so crazy so I'm like learning
all this stuff about my history and my
in my arm that's when you get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] from dude you got it
from your grandma dude she's just full
of [ __ ] like anytime that was a rule
she's like [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
whoever I want I want to be educated you
I don't wanna [ __ ] read son yeah
that's tight you know she drove like she
did like a lot of like like driving for
women is like it's like pretty edgy you
know isn't that interesting cuz you
would this is on your mom's side yeah is
my mom's side so it's weird because the
way you describe your mom
she seems to be relatively a lot more
tame than that yeah so it skipped the
generation and then it went to you well
my mom said that my grandma was so
assertive to the point where she was too
controlling so my mom didn't have to do
anything cuz she grew up with like her
her mom like doing everything for her so
she said that like when she was little
she didn't have a voice cuz my my
grandma would be like what do you want
to be when
grow up and my mom was like I don't want
to be a schoolteacher and then my
grandma would be like no you're gonna be
a nurse but that's so [ __ ] weird
because your mom hated that yeah but she
would still do it to her own kid not not
necessarily yeah I mean like I had a lot
of freedom but she wanted me to be a mom
your grandma oh you're a mom right right
that cuz your mom was trying to learn
from the other way around a little bit
right yeah when your mom got older and
your guys's relationship started getting
closer
she started changing her ways a little
bit maybe in reflection of what she had
with her parent but because your grandma
fought against what her parents want you
would have thought that would have
trickled now she's a stubborn ox man
that's [ __ ] crazy
cuz it's a little hypocritical of her
right it is it's like wait hold on a
second
you were happy being the tomboy with the
[ __ ] titled hair yeah [ __ ]
whatever dick you wanted and also with
your own daughter you're like you're
still gonna listen to what I say yeah so
odd I wouldn't think that would be the
case I think she just has a really
strong personality man cuz like she used
to live in my house so the day she flew
into the states to kind of live with us
is the day I was born
yeah and I guess like it's been
turbulent in the house ever since she
came in yeah cuz she's got she's so
[ __ ] headstrong and you know like in
an Asian family like it's very
patriarchy like yes I could father's
supposed to be the top dog right yeah
but then also the oldest supposed to be
the top dog uh-huh so there's always
this battle between my dad and my
grandma my dad's not he's not articulate
he's not intelligent like he's a
musician that just cares about his music
yeah so he wasn't really good at
explaining himself or arguing his points
and my grandma's so damn good that she
just always [ __ ] ran circles around
him and he would get so frustrated cuz
he cuz he can't explain himself right so
it got to the point where he had she had
to go oh I kicked her out and then oh no
no she would move she moved to NorCal
and lived with my uncle oh my god that's
hard man because I know that my mom
super headstrong too yeah but even I
mean she says it though she's gonna
understand that you know
it comes to me you know when Muriel not
getting married that's gonna be our
household like you could stay say your
opinions but if I don't take it you're
just gonna have to understand it's not
your household yeah
so that's I think that's the hard part
is when a parent doesn't know to
understand that your child's life is
their life yeah at a certain point you
know you're gonna have to let go of
those reins and allow them to live and
I'm saying this too right now somebody
who isn't a parent but cuz I know I'm
gonna have trouble with that [ __ ] I used
to had that trouble with friends right
so when I was younger and this is
something that I used to hate about
myself that I learned to fix is how I
used to give advice versus forcing
somebody to take it and what's a lot of
people [ __ ] up on the [ __ ] a lot because
it's something I used to do when I was
in my teens yeah so for example when a
friend would come up to me and asked for
advice I would give them advice and if
they didn't take it I would hate them
for it yeah you know it's like well
why'd you [ __ ] ask me in the first
you wasted my time
yeah cuz I invested my feelings yeah
exactly which is kind of stupid though
because how you should give advice or in
my opinion is when you give somebody
advice or you tell something that you
might think may be beneficial for them
it's up to that person decide whether
the opinion or not and you as a friend
are just being there just to support
them and try to help them out if they
don't take it it's on them you didn't
waste your time because they were help
for whatever it wasn't that purpose you
know in that time you know it's annoying
those when they keep coming back and
asking the same question that's a little
different like you know holes ask quite
so many [ __ ] friends they would ask
you questions and try to convince you
like they're to know what the answer is
but they don't want a minute they just
want confirmation for their thoughts
yeah so they would just be like oh don't
you think it's kind of funny and stupid
to do it this way don't you think it's
like no I don't think that but don't you
think umm it's like shut up do you want
me to just agree yeah yeah go out and
tell other people like Joe thinks that -
yeah you know like it's a damn that's
just then just wanted to hear them so
speak at that point yeah I just kind of
look for the confirmation from you yeah
what they're doing it drives me crazy
cuz it's like you don't want to solve a
problem you just want to confirm your
own thoughts and be right yeah and you
know like giving advice to sometimes
hard because like sometimes I'll preface
now that I'm older and I tend to be a
lot more straightforward than I was when
I was younger I'll always ask somebody
hey
you want me to give it to you straight
or do you want me to say it in a way
that will spare your feelings a little
bit so you had that option right and I
always say yo take take everything that
I say with the grain of salt
yes I'm not you yeah so I'll give an
option so if they could take the harsh
one then you made that choice you know
even like I've literally like for
example like I mentioned this before but
when somebody was asking that they
wanted to be an actor and they came up
to me with some [ __ ] and I [ __ ]
roasted the [ __ ] out of them yeah you
know and I was like well this is the
advice that you wanted you came up with
some stupid thoughts and I wanted to
crush that [ __ ] before you moved on to
the next step and then fail yeah you
know so like those [ __ ] are kind of
annoying just because it's like what do
you what are you here for yeah that's
the point of this they don't even know
that they're being an [ __ ] because
that in that kind of point it's just
it's like that whole take take and take
relationship yeah because there are
certain people that come into your life
that only come to you when they need
something from you
yeah and they're emotionally exhausting
yes when you get older men like that
that that threshold for [ __ ] gets
smaller and smaller yo and smaller so I
tend to invest my emotions of the people
I care about but if I don't care about
you I really don't give a [ __ ] what
happens to you for sure that's the hard
part
yeah I mean that's all about being
mature right is like knowing when to
invest your heart into something
yeah and knowing when to care it's like
controlling all that is like a mastery
like it's it's hard it's hard as [ __ ]
because everything is annoying yeah I
think one I mean you and I had the
similar problem I think it's just
because we go it was [ __ ] angry
Japanese Korean people like when we feel
something we want to express it
immediately yeah and sometimes you just
need a [ __ ] step back and be like is
it worth [ __ ] punching this person in
the face you know like it's just not it
what does it do yeah exactly
and I had to learn that the hard way
specifically being in a long-term
relationship oh yeah because you know
this too this is this is was is just
your longest relationship right yeah
she's she's the longest from Ariel is my
longest relationship - yeah so like the
biggest thing I had to learn was to
control my [ __ ] mouth yes and not
just like how would I feel at the
[ __ ] moment yeah cuz typically before
when I was with somebody if I had like
their [ __ ] decided Pease [ __ ] yeah
and then you'll find someone else yeah
I'll find somebody else I need to hear
your [ __ ] [ __ ] but then when it comes
to somebody that you want to be with for
a very long time that you actually care
about you have to learn how to control
these impulses you don't have to be
mindful of people's emotions at how they
feel and you want that same return back
yeah so like I just remember even I
think more so for her it was more
difficult because like I I understand
like I'm not very typical in terms of
like the people that normal people are
with I think you two we're not very
typical right yeah we don't really we're
just different you know I mean yeah a
lot of people they know how to maneuver
their words well yeah we're they're more
tack board they just they just hold back
saying certain things yeah so it's like
most people don't say things like that
where we just let it all out yeah and
sometimes it's too much oh yeah
definitely
you know like for example you know we
talked about this to where the the
qualities that you [ __ ] love about
somebody are the same [ __ ] reasons
you hate them yeah like like for example
did here's a great example for guys out
there yeah so you meet this girl right
she's beautiful she's lovely
whatever all right and you also like the
fact that she's a strong woman that has
a very strong opinion about a lot of
things and completely honest great
that's what we want
yes what we asked for problem is that
[ __ ] gets [ __ ] annoying sometimes
it's like chilling sometimes a girl will
look at you me like once you get that
crust off your face you're ugly I'm like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] I was just I was
eating a bagel why you got it like
that's what I asked for I asked for this
like unfiltered like woman with the
strong opinion yeah but when I'm eating
my cream cheese and bagel how about you
not calling me ugly huh how about that
[ __ ] yeah exactly dude I'm just like
I'm brushing my teeth and I'm like why I
gotta call me fat I just my Dino my
belly jiggles when I when I'm brushing
my teeth I'm telling you man
that's like the the the the lesson that
I learned early on is like oh [ __ ]
everything that I love about you is the
same reason why I [ __ ] hate ya dude
but I do still appreciate it though
because I think I've been with so many
relationships where I'm like please just
communicate with me I want to have a
conversation I can't even have a
conversation with you because you can't
even express your words you know you
can't you
what's going on in here you can't even
say it out loud because a lot of these
girls they grew up being told to shut up
by their parents or something whatever
it is they're afraid to speak and maybe
it's more prevalent in the
asian-american community where like if
you have my parents a lot of them you
know and that's where like being
passive-aggressive and all these other
things come out and they hold resentment
because you can't solve issues and I'm
just like praying to God like please I
just want to I want a partner that I can
just sit down and honestly have a
conversation with and try to solve [ __ ]
together with so that's what I [ __ ]
love about it is like I got what I
wanted yeah but while I'm it when I'm
sitting there eating the cheeto just
watching TV yeah I'll have to slap your
bad tip you know I found out like III
remember just thinking I wanted a girl
who was you know just didn't have I want
I don't want to say opinions but was
just kind of chill about everything
right it turns out I actually dislike
that girl the most yeah it's because
it's that thing of having to try to
figure out what they're thinking right
dislike right and I also grew up in a
household where my mom was a highly
opinionated yeah about [ __ ] everything
about so that's the type of woman that I
grew up with so I grew up around women
who were number one highly opinionated
wasn't afraid to speak their crap crass
is [ __ ] yeah you know just very strong
right and for some reason I thought I
wanted the exact opposite that I wanted
a strong woman who but who was still
quiet didn't really give a [ __ ] about a
lot of things that's not true at all the
last girlfriend I had was like that yeah
bored me too [ __ ] dirt yeah like we
would we would have arguments about
certain things and I think I would say
things that I just wanted to see what
she was thinking and she would just be
like you're probably right it's like no
you can't respect someone who doesn't
stand their ground yeah like yeah you
think I need to know what what is going
on in your mind right and maybe to her
arguments she's like I don't want to
fight about it there's nothing to fight
I just want to hear what you think cuz
we yeah get to a point where we should
be able to discuss about these things
civilly well I mean a lot of a lot of
people grow up in a household where like
any kind any type of discussion or
disagreement is considered like
challenging your parents or like oh like
disrespect its district
so then I don't I don't think they're
comfortable expressing their thoughts in
a Korean household - I used to hear this
[ __ ] all the time especially when I kind
of like I guess in their mind talk back
yeah but not by the quiz so that means
that why are you always talking back
that's what I heard - it was like I was
just asking questions cuz I want to
learn yeah I want I don't want to [ __ ]
up next time but then I just get smacked
across the face and it's like yo have
common sense you should know already
know that was what I was told and I'm
like damn dude like well [ __ ] I don't
even want to say anything yeah and
there's like another thing that a lot of
great people say goes don't go to Milan
that means you don't even know that [ __ ]
yeah yeah you don't know that [ __ ] like
what do you mean but you know what
though um you know like like at this age
now my mom she cries and she tells me
like [ __ ] you you helped me wake up like
she was like when you would challenge us
back in a day and ask certain questions
that we had no answer to it would
challenge our ego and we you know that
pride would get hurt so we would turn it
back on to you and and and be punish you
for even asking those questions but
instead of sitting there in working
through these thoughts like adults like
we were so tired and like she was just
like [ __ ] I'm so sorry like we all could
have been better
and I'm like that's awesome like the
point that you're telling me this now
to me that's awesome that's all I can
ask for but it just sucks that like this
is very prevalent in an immigrant
household or like a you know like
parents with pride like you know mean
like and and when they grow up doing it
that way like it happens in a
relationship too like you don't know how
to speak to each other yeah and then to
your mom's credit what she actually said
to is very true especially in an
immigrant family when they come to the
states it's it's hard for people to say
to somebody who doesn't have money who
doesn't have resources and say why don't
you just sit down and talk to your kids
yo when you're working [ __ ] like 80 90
hours a week yeah that's the kind of
like the last thing that you want to do
and you can say as much as you want well
if it's for your kid you should put that
time in you should look and in your
household - unhappy marriage you know
right wanted to leave their partner
financially things are [ __ ] up right
kids up maybe has maybe you were like
super excitable you're all over the
place I had ADHD yeah you
and the fastest way to punish a kid is
just smack them upside the head and tell
me don't ask [ __ ] questions because
that's the only way they know how to
deal with it and it's hard to ground a
kid and take something away from a kid
when they don't really have much right
what are you gonna take away from me I'm
broke
you're poor on board we're sorrounding
there's no ground as a toady a real
great I'm a [ __ ] jackoff do you know
that's a great time for me you know so
like you know when that whole ground I
remember my dad actually tried to ground
me yeah didn't do [ __ ] nah it didn't do
[ __ ] on my grounding cool go to my room
man I'm gonna just start drawing yeah
I'm just gonna chill dude I remember one
time my dad I forgot he punished me this
fool got so [ __ ] mad because after
the punishment happened all that cool I
went to my room and I started practicing
singing this Brian nice line is your
[ __ ] see I'm just trying to [ __ ]
sing it my feelings dog like let me get
my R&B on and this will beat my ass now
scene so bright at night
do I ever cross your mind and he goes
what the [ __ ] you saying dude this is
how you reflect on your punishment and
he starts beating my ass again and my
mom comes you know why are you hitting
him he goes cuz he's singing she what
I'm saying
[ __ ] if I look back at the fight it's so
ridiculous dude
why are you singing my love look just
think about what he's doing wrong he's
thinking love songs how is that
reflecting up and I'm just sitting there
just crying he's trying to sing a Brian
McKnight song in my [ __ ] room get in
my head with a song that you [ __ ] up
on imagine if it was like a him I know
[Music]
you believe you pray the Jesus to pour
your soul Ocasek you might pucker 20,000
Hail Marys but it doesn't he'll marry
[ __ ] dude that's [ __ ] so true
man and it sucks because there's a lot
of people still in that like we went
through a rollercoaster but there's
people out there right now that's going
through it and people listening or like
people that went through it and they
never really like dealt with it you know
like they never like came to this like
peace with their parents like they still
hold on to that [ __ ]
I get a little sad too because sometimes
the foundation that you have with your
parents wasn't said in order for you to
have a comfortable conversation with
them and you know like we mentioned this
on a previous podcast where it's it's
just there's no empathy on both sides
like you're not understanding where your
parents came from yeah and they're not
really trying to understand you so it
kind of works both ways like my dad the
last time we had a huge fight we had a
heart-to-heart and he said this that
kind of you know struck a chord with me
and I told him I was like you know you
consistently want to have a relationship
with me and then my mom told me this too
and she goes you know what you should
feel bad for your dad and I was like why
he goes not pity him but think about
this like he grew up in a broken
household where you know my dad's story
is [ __ ] crazy
yeah then we'll get that and we get into
that at another time but she goes he has
always wanted a close family right but
because he wanted this close family his
expectation of what he thinks a family
should be is skewed because he didn't
have that oh so he's imagining like
perfection examining the reality that's
not what a close family is whatever yeah
so he wants you to he wants to us to buy
a big house where we live in it you live
in it your family lives in like a
multi-generational home yeah but like he
had a conversation with my dad she goes
if you wanted that you wanted your son
to be a Korean person yeah why the [ __ ]
did you take us to America yeah why yeah
like how can you have this expectation
for your son to be a Korean Korean
person when you chose to raise him in a
different environment that was your
choice why are you so annoying if you
want people close to you you know that's
the thing because he doesn't know how to
connect some time and uh you know to his
credit he's trying yeah he's very
socially awkward in that sense and I
have to learn how to maneuver around
this because I told him when we had the
huge are you Michael well why can't you
just talk to me
yes have a car don't lecture me don't
tell me how to live my life just [ __ ]
talk to me like how mom does when mom
and I talk we just talk about [ __ ]
and we have a good time and he said to
me he goes David I didn't have that when
me and your you know your grandma yeah
how I talked to you that's how your
grandma talks to me or when she was
alive your grandpa that's how he talked
to me
yeah I don't know how to do his commands
yeah because you're asking me to do some
that I was never looked taught how to do
and I don't know how to do so that's not
fair for you to say that to me and I was
like oh oh yeah it's I mean true but man
you got to learn it yeah you know we all
got alerts heart he does sometimes know
how to have a conversation with my mom
so that's crazy cuz he's a pastor and
you would think that a pastor is so
socially wealthy with like yeah well and
you know I or is it because he's always
in a higher position that people come to
him for comfort and he's really good at
listening and giving advice and being
lecture II kind of I feel like in a
Korean Church and it's more like they
look at the the book signing the pastor
is such a as such a revered person
anyway they're called book sons books
are books on oh as dope cuz we call it
book sheet that's very similar yeah yeah
yeah and so they're looked at in a
revered state so most of the time these
pastors yeah they you know they have
meals with each other they eat and stuff
but it's more like they're coming to
them as a higher person as a counselor
so he's speaking to them versus having a
great conversation yeah and so that's
the thing that used to always throw me
off cuz in the back of my mind as a kid
I always thought to my dad it's like how
come you are so good to your church
people but you're not that great to me
like a family but that really wasn't the
case
the form of communication was different
and you know learning to had that
speaking moment with my dad is when I
learned a lot about him because I just
learned oh [ __ ] he never he doesn't know
how to do this and I'm expecting him to
do something my mom's good at but my
mom's just different yeah my mom's my
mom is different she's not like most
Korean parents she's just a weirdo she's
a [ __ ] weirdo when Mariel met my
mom's yeah well your mom's really easy
to talk to she super fun and now there's
no separation right like most
traditional Asian families there's like
this hierarchy and the separations
pretty different
like there's you you do have that level
of respect where they're almost a
stranger every single time you see them
yeah right if there's there's this
there's this love but there's no like
that grounded level of love yes almost
like I don't want to say force but it's
like I love you because you're my parent
you know and not because I love you
because I love you in other households
you see yeah yeah and so I think like I
got kind of fortunate in the sense of
how I connect with
mom is like that and now my now my dad
too after we worked our [ __ ] out so
that's cuz your mom is more folksy right
like yeah she's country yes yeah dude
this woman's a bumpkin dude yeah like if
I drew a picture of my mom just picture
like Crocs [ __ ] swishy pants a
[ __ ] vest from North Face and a week
coming out but I feel like that
stereotypes true like all over the world
like the more country you are the more
like human you are the more closer you
are the more down-to-earth yeah then the
more like prestigious or city or
whatever the stereotype is like yeah
you're more like fake really or just
political yeah and there's just a lot of
like conversation to that I think I
started to learn when I was older like
especially with our friends and personal
relations that we do have and you know
this now - it's when my dad used to say
something to me when I was a kid I used
to get super combative with it yeah and
he would be like eight when you meet a
girl understand where her family comes
from yeah and I looked at in life
dude you judgmental [ __ ] man but if
he's Oh true yeah yeah you go judge
these people before you even get to meet
them yes you're such a piece of [ __ ] but
what my dad was saying was how you grow
up is a direct reflection of what you
become when you're older yeah they just
suck at explaining things exactly and
they're not wrong they're not wrong
right but it's a you know as a young
person that's very combative I think if
he would have better explain it then I
would have better understood it cuz all
I heard was you don't want me to marry a
black girl you know you don't want me to
marry my latina he did but you don't
like [ __ ] Mexican chicks I love that
booty you know that's all I was thinking
but what he was saying was that if
somebody comes from a broken home you're
gonna see that reflected in their lives
yeah and it's something a burden that
you're gonna have to carry as well and I
started finding that out when I started
dating people yeah a lot of girls with
daddy issues had very similar problems
same thing with boys with mommy issues
have very similar problems
yeah I'd also holy [ __ ] he's right he
was [ __ ] right well I mean definitely
broken home I mean that that's something
that's what brings me close with Jess
because of our experiences yeah but what
we realize is like so she was raised by
her dad I was raised by my mom yeah and
we both have this expectation of what a
our male and female figures should be
yeah but we don't know how to act like a
good male or female figure so for
example she knows what a good dad is
supposed to be like right but she
doesn't know how to fill that role of a
good female because there's no female
role model and and for me it's like I
have expectations about what a what a
good female role models supposed to be
yeah but I don't know how to fill the
role of a good male role model yeah so
that's a huge thing that we realize like
oh wow like we have these weird
expectations but we don't know how to
put in the work because we didn't have a
good role model of that figure like a
good male figure and a good female
figure yeah so yeah there's definitely
extra baggage and things that you have
to work through but I mean that's kind
of the beauty of it is when you can
relate and not turn against each other
you could really work together as a team
yeah yeah and it's it's you know you get
to that point man and getting to that
point too is so hard because you have to
fight and fight yeah I don't know how
people do it man because it's not only
emotionally exhausting but you have to
self-reflect and be very intelligent
about the way you do things
yeah - it's hard man because we're all
animals like I mean just the type of
households we grow up grew up in I look
back and I'm like my family was a bunch
of [ __ ] baboon
we were like monkeys [ __ ] in our
hands throwing it at each other
yo yo I tell the story - all the time
you I witnessed my mom throw a feel the
rice cooker up my dad's head yeah yeah I
saw my mom take a rice cooker rip it out
from the hall and chuck it at my dad if
you go to my house you'll see where that
were the counter cracked and my dad put
cement glue and reattached it from where
my mom missed him just do the rice
cooker bunch of apes dude people yelling
in the house like I mean you know it's
it's such an unintelligent way to live
like it's it's such a bad bad way to
like just be a human being it's almost
like you lose control and you become
this animal yeah and you're just acting
it's so stupid
I get you know and I think too we always
tried to not be the things that we hated
seeing growing up
but sometimes that's just like embedded
in you and it just seeps out like yeah I
see the stuff that my dad does the
pisses my mom off you're like you idiot
why do you do that [ __ ] yeah and I do
the same [ __ ] to Muriel oh no like for
example like when we first started going
out
I didn't know when to cut out the jokes
so I would always make fun of her so
your dad is a big jokester yes and he
beat like dude he says some [ __ ]
savage a [ __ ] so he just keeps roasting
all day long yeah and he doesn't know
when to cut that [ __ ] out and then my
mom get [ __ ] him said like I remember
one time we were eating a dinner and
then my brother was there too and then
we were in tears laughing but then my
mom was not having it because my mom
cooked some food and my mom loves
cooking right so you just generally know
you don't [ __ ] around with the stuff
that people love a lot yeah so my mom
the way that she connects us cooking
food so she's cooking the food as she
makes something for my dad it's like
this beef dish and my dad eats and he
goes it's uh it's kind of tough right
and my mom's like that's not tough it's
delicious
yeah right and I'm not laughing and now
my mom eats it she goes look it's fine
by me like my teeth are okay and then my
dad looks at her he goes you call those
things dangling from your mouth teeth
not only does he did the cookies her
teeth I was busting up in tears laughing
oh and then my mom is not laughing she's
just sitting there just mad dogging him
like what the [ __ ] did you just say to
me so [ __ ] up because she just grabbed
the food out she goes don't eat the [ __ ]
baby up my brother just laughing good
just like watch your mouth please don't
eat it
this is recently this is like a few
years back oh my god but that's the type
of [ __ ] my dad says what do you have
said that if there was no audience like
yes he will just fight like that every
day that's why they fight cuz my dad
always says some insensitive ass [ __ ] or
he he hasn't why does he take out his do
that I don't know he thinks is funny you
know oh good yeah that's like fun do
that's there's consequences I always say
like I always say like you you know if
you play with fire and you get burnt
that's your fault yeah I mean if you're
gonna do that joke just [ __ ] man you're
you you're getting what's coming to you
okay there's some weird stuff like
learning just watching my parents don't
like oh wow dude they're just normal
people man they're not like they're like
normal people
[ __ ] the way they the things that they
fight about it's the same [ __ ] that I
fight about yeah and I start to learn a
little bit more about myself as I as I
begin to observe my parents cuz you put
them on a pedestal and then you realize
oh man you guys are [ __ ] dumb yeah yo
I wish I'd learned this [ __ ] when I was
younger though cuz then I think I would
have had a lot more empathy towards them
but I started learning it only like four
or five years ago yeah which kind of
sucks cuz I wasted like 25 years well
they have a different face for us yeah
so you know well also your parents stuck
together yeah I think when when you do
come from a broken home you learn really
quick that they're not invent they're
not invincible
cuz you see the the household split yeah
you see the weakness and then you see
you lose respect and then you go ah like
you're pretty weak your mom does she
I would never guess that she is that old
because the way you [ __ ] describe her
did you said you described her like she
was the Crypt Keeper dude like she was
this old dusty [ __ ] were just like
[ __ ] powders coming out of her
[ __ ]
she's like a fairy dude she's [ __ ] a
fetus [ __ ] she looks good I know she's
like [ __ ] 72 or some [ __ ] yeah she's
like seven years maybe like six years
older than my mom yeah but she looks
maybe arguably younger than my mom
really you think so I think she's just
she's so sprightly yeah well Jess young
energy for sure yeah she has a lot of
youth in her like she's a cheerful
person man like it's it's she's always
been that way I think she's a bit
bipolar yeah she goes through these
spurts of high intense happiness and
like she'll just be tired as [ __ ] and
then she just goes up and down like that
she's still working right now no she
retired
oh when did she retire Shay years ago
were like four or five years ago I was
like children right now hey yeah yeah
but she meets she worked into her well
into her sixties man and she had a she
worked graveyard at the Retirement
Center she was a nurse and all that
stuff mmm but like she lived most of her
life servicing others and she told me
like she lived so much of her life like
as a service to others that
she doesn't know how to live for herself
mmm like like you know when she got
married or before she married my dad she
was you know she was like living like
through my grandma's vision and decision
yeah and then once she married my dad
she was like like a good follower to him
yeah and then after that you know she
was living with me and then she went and
pretty much went to go take care of my
grandma in Japan so she went back to
Japan like 15 years ago or something
like that and then so she all of her
life like she's been living to basically
serve others she's just a giver man she
makes she gets so happy giving and
giving and gave me she has no ideas on
her own and then once she retired she
was just like I don't know what to do
mmm like I really don't she's like I
thank goodness she started dating
somebody and someone who absolutely
loved her so like my stepdad like he's
the opposite of her you know like very
very adventurous like he loves traveling
like he's a straight-up fo be like he
stowed away on a cargo ship and came to
America got his citizenship you know
back thing he's an American citizen yeah
he says back then it was easier to be an
illegal immigrant and then just get your
citizenship oh it was way easier before
9/11 dude yeah it was super yeah well
yeah well it's especially for Japanese
citizens yeah so he came in here he
worked for the government Washington DC
like he spoke English I mean his English
is pretty damn good right so and like
you know he rode motorcycles and he just
loved traveling so so him being with my
mom was really awesome because he pushes
her to like try [ __ ] like my mom she
wouldn't even eat street food because
she's afraid that we're gonna look at
her and judge her yeah well because like
like I said like she grew up in that
prestigious world that's right that's Oh
likes for them eating street food eating
eating you know at yeah yeah it's like
oh I don't want people to see me because
I'm not of this class and it's like
[ __ ] no one even cares anymore like
we're not in a caste system you know
like no
no I know it was like like you just you
just brought up that way to think that
like oh we're a family of prestige so we
can't do this we can't do the commoner
stuff or else there's gonna be rumors
and then he's gonna make the family look
bad but it's like well [ __ ] bad you know
bad news but that's been over with no
one gives a [ __ ] about her family no one
knows we exist yeah you know but it's in
her mind still so she can't even sit
down and enjoy Bhutan or stand and eat
like eat food on the subway so me and
like her husband like my except dad
we're just sitting there we're eating
street food were laughing and she's just
standing there like no it's okay and
well like come on you know eat it with
this but he's getting her to try she she
she's looking at you like you're a
[ __ ] Savage well what I love about is
she never pushed those things onto me
yeah yeah she was like I'm so happy that
you're the opposite of me because you're
so like adventurous and she's like
that's why I didn't put too many rules
on you cuz yeah I didn't want you to
grow up in fear like me yeah so so so
it's good because this you know this guy
does a man like he's so adventurous and
he's taking her to the Vietnam
Philippines all these other countries
day he's she didn't want any Japanese
Street food she's over gonna be it not
right she's eating Street food out in
Vietnam do all kinds of [ __ ] lady in
tiger dick yeah and how she eats street
food you know like but she's really
blossomed out of that she'll thanks to
him
damn she went to Vietnam that's some
different [ __ ] dude she's over there
they're chopping up [ __ ] starfish and
eating that [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ]
wild man yeah it's like she got a new
lease on life yeah yeah and it was crazy
he's watching him date and [ __ ] like oh
I saw this child like I saw this like
girl with a crush and I'm like damn dude
this old geezers like falling in love
and [ __ ] that's looking tight yeah and
yeah it was crazy she's like oh this is
what he texted me I'm like damn what the
[ __ ] like Oh gross [ __ ] which mean
texted like what you see some weird ass
but we do some old people flirty like I
am thinking about you just with the
period I can't wait for our date
are you gonna take your Metamucil before
make sure you take your gas tank so you
don't fart it up let me know I [ __ ]
love you oh that's so [ __ ] crazy man
yeah
sometimes when I see my parents for it
it sickens me okay I know they're
holding Fleur too I saw them one time
when I came back from college like they
were chasing each other in the backyard
I was like gross the [ __ ] are you doing
nasty so I guess I guess you you you say
a lot of the arguments and fights they
do but then like they do have a
friendship too of course like yeah my I
mean those jokes that my dad's make when
they hit hard they hit well but when
they go bad they go really bad but he's
a funny guy and you know - my dad is
somebody who was very caring like he's
he is - his fault he was a little too
caring which is why he got burned a lot
so when you the the hard part about
giving and giving and giving is that
there you will find people who would
take advantage of your kindness is he
like overbearing caring type - though
where he's like too much well it's not
that so much is that he used to be
somebody that just if you saw somebody
struggle he would be the first person to
help them out
oh that's awesome you know and that's
what made him a preacher probably
exactly you know and that's like the the
the christ-like thing that he came from
the religion right miss to always lend a
helping hand and I don't think he was
sometime was emotionally prepared for
people to take advantage of his kindness
mm-hmm and that happened a lot to him
like I remember this lady she lost story
short we sold a we had two businesses
right both of them are going really well
we own a beauty supply store and they
weren't too far away from each other so
this lady had a fish and chip business
it was dying out she saw these burgers
used to bring it to us all the time my
son loved those burgers her business
without you it wasn't doing too well and
she said that she wanted to stay in the
States but if she didn't have a viable
business she had to go back to Korea and
live out over there and then she wasn't
a citizen she was but then she was like
oh she couldn't make it here yeah she
didn't either I don't want to go back
and then my dad was like okay cool so we
had this other business that was doing
well and so he goes hey I have this
other business and I'm thinking about
maybe letting it go selling it and
making some money off of it but also to
you for a little less than what we met
what we bought
for when we started it up for so it was
we lost a [ __ ] ton of money on it but he
wanted to help her out because she was a
family friend yeah he goes well if I'm
gonna sell just sell to somebody that I
care about so he sells it to her right
so like within a month she puts it back
up in the market makes a profit profit
off of it well we would have made a
profit off took that money she moved to
create anyways Wow so she took advantage
of my dad's kindness Wow and stuff like
that happened to my dad a lot and so he
got burnt from it yeah and so I started
hoping she would stick around and make
make that business boom yeah and you see
a person dime
made a life for herself here yeah she
told my dad a sob story yeah and then my
dad sold her for pennies stuck to the
dollar hey Sean flip it took the money
and moved to Korea and so now it's like
[ __ ] if I ever see that lady I'm [ __ ]
Spartan kinging that [ __ ] in her uterus
dude I don't give a look but my dad got
burned for that type of stuff and a good
thing she's out of America oh thank god
she is dude I don't she's probably like
70 year old I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
choking that [ __ ] out dude lambda
dentures out her yes but she my dad
would get burned by people like this
dude there's so many other stories to
where my dad got hurt yeah and so he
tried to pass these lessons on to me so
he try to make me very skeptical about
trusting people which to be honest with
you helped me out a lot yeah like I've
only had really one bad business partner
and that was my fault because I had my
guard down yeah I have my I have my
defenses up which saved my ass half way
through but it would have been better if
I just trusted my instincts that my dad
kind of its put into me mm-hmm
but yeah he just he just got burned so
[ __ ] much from trusting people and
that's the hard part about being a
gaming person is that you will face his
experiences but he wasn't prepared for
the bad stuff but he was always prepared
for the good yeah and so it kind of wore
on him a lot so he would always tell me
be careful about who you trust yeah
don't just trust anybody that are
likeable people in this world which is
your story I always tell people there's
likeable people but it doesn't mean that
they're good people exactly and that's
what would happen to my dad but you're a
pastor this one yes I post it do have to
you give out a loan tot that that's why
now even when I give money to people I
don't expect them to return it back yeah
yeah yeah we talked about this last time
you were like yeah yeah we just give you
just give and in like if they do then
they do but then once that leaves your
pocket it's like hey it was
meant to help them yeah yeah it is what
it is but it's important to have street
smarts though
oh yeah what your dad is like blindly
loving and giving which is like you know
only God could do that cuz we're human
beings yeah and like you say it like
[ __ ] you give too much you it's gonna
it's gonna burn you the [ __ ] out you're
gonna start having a pessimistic view
about human beings but in my like I
don't know I think over the years I've
built this intuition about people and
sure like I've made mistakes choosing
wrong people or whatever but I think at
the end of the day like you got to do it
in steps
yeah you can't you can't all of a sudden
shower someone with like overwhelming
gifts right yeah like you got to kind of
test the relationship like for all the
people that I do business with now like
I'm so confident in in trusting of the
relationship that I don't have to worry
about anything
because we find people who are way
better than us like I look at that I
judge Ted like what the [ __ ] you
trusting me for dude like what's wrong
with you
yeah there's such sweet people man yeah
and you know I think that's the that's
one of the lessons that we learned was
to maybe not so much trust in the
business but trust in the people exactly
that's that's all I've always done yeah
is people always ask me like oh why
don't you like do it this way on in your
business or like why don't you hire
these kind of skilled people or whatever
and I'm like I'm a man that's not my
system my system is yeah it's I like
these people I could depend on them I
trust them so that's it yeah that's all
it is it's super simple I mean I can go
the other route and be like the
corporate style where it's soulless and
it's just all about skills and all about
getting the job done but why I would
have just worked in the company if I
wanted to be a shark like that yo I'm
trying to learn you know this year to
figure out things that make me hype off
you see money makes me happy too which I
don't have a lot of anymore but like
just like something small right for
example at sparks joy what dude [ __ ]
you know I I was first of all I was
[ __ ] up her name I thought her name
was
maricon which also means
money clock would be like Fagin and
Spanish or something I was calling her
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I was like Mattie come on Mattie : my
and my friends like Mattie condo oh yeah
oh it's not mad econ I was like what's
body cuz I sound so familiar because
that means like [ __ ] it's better I was
like saying [ __ ] all over the place so
bad I had no idea I wasn't trying to say
that I'm just like Mattie corn sounds so
familiar
I was it oh because it's a it's a it's a
very derogatory word so I like dog she's
been um like I watched her show on no
but I've heard about her for a while
because of her book and it blew up it
kind of taught people not not so much
not to have to waste your money on
buying things
it's about organizing your life and
figure out what purpose it has yeah
right which held it up with a lot of
things that have purpose yeah instead of
a lot of clutter yeah that just takes up
space does it spark joy and that was the
biggest question and so when I was
watching it it kind of coincided with my
new year's goal of trying to figure out
what makes you happy and it's just to
have things just to have it doesn't make
me how it's the purpose or the reason or
the sentiment or that whatever exactly
and so like it even goes back to
something small as for me when I was
going through a lot of [ __ ] like
specifically trying to figure out what I
was doing dude I just started buying
things and in my spare time just because
of that momentary happiness that I got
from fine you know ooh oh wow
damn yep and it felt good I mean that
was me collecting Spears and swords I
could smash some [ __ ]
watermelons and it was like all this
like stuff that made me temporarily
happy yeah and one of the biggest things
that I'm learning now it's like why am i
spending this money on this you know it
doesn't matter if I have the money to
spend it on it like what can I be doing
with this and it's just filling my house
with garbage yeah like what the [ __ ] am
i doing you know even even like this I'm
giving up the Tesla this year right and
like now arguably I could keep it and
then you know be happy with this car
it's cool but it served its purpose yeah
so let it go like do I want it what is
it what is the reason why I want to keep
this Tesla it's because honestly it's
just if I'm just gonna be a hundred
percent real it's part two stunts like
saying like yo I could afford this car
this in the heart that I have so when we
had this conversation and people have
people look at and you know I read this
and
- yeah they're like why don't you keep
acting like you're not rich like you're
not a millionaire yeah you dumb [ __ ]
you think if I'm a [ __ ] millionaire I
would be doing a podcast in my own
[ __ ] house I would be setting up this
camera myself I would be setting up this
you [ __ ] up if I was a man I would
let everybody know I would be the guy
that walks around with the water cash
and I'd slept the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
you
and I toss a dollar in your face you you
are technically a millionaire and assets
kind of your you might not be cash rich
I have that's what people don't
understand about is like like in our
stages in our 30s right like as business
owners like we're still in the game of
growth yeah I mean we can choose to cash
out early we can but that's that's too
fast I'm poor we're I mean I'm cash poor
because a lot of the money that I do get
to as I invest it immediately yeah so
most of my money and value is in
businesses isn't investments isn't all
these other things and yeah I mean like
what you all must did is after he sold
PayPal he put all of that [ __ ]
inside Tesla and uh and and he was like
living in an apartment or some [ __ ] yeah
he was bankrupt or whatever people don't
understand there's something even
something as simple as this so we I did
a podcast recently with edrick and then
I was talking to him about the
go-for-broke situation with yes right
and I didn't realize that people didn't
understand the difference between gross
profit and net profit which is something
so basic well I mean if they didn't go
to school for business or even own a
business yeah and so don't know they
don't know the difference you know a
couple of like messages that I got
they're like how that doesn't make any
sense how could you be how could go for
broke go from making zero to about seven
figures and then you guys couldn't
handle it you guys should be rich but
I'm like listen that's not how it works
right like there's something also called
manageable growth right just because
something grows if you don't set up the
systems in place to help you run that
business you're just gonna go bankrupt
actually mmm because you put all your
resources and money into trying to
manage and run something that you don't
know how to run yourself yeah so
everybody else gets paid to do it but so
you walk away with nothing yeah so to
basically sum it up for all of you who
don't know the difference between gross
profit and net profit so
Rose puppet is just basically money
coming in it's technically not profit is
gross income yes so it's all the money
just coming into your business all the
sales right but the net profit is when
you subtract the costs of operating so
like let's say we have a t-shirt company
right like and then but first we have to
put up the money to make the t-shirt get
the design on the t-shirt ship the
t-shirt all that stuff and and that is
the cost of the operation we also have
to pay the customer service people all
that stuff these are all costs right and
then maybe the rent or whatever so you
factor that in in in that is the cost of
the shirt right and then you sell it for
like let's say like it like the cost of
seven dollars and then we sell it for
like like thirty dollars right so the
left over that is the net yeah and yeah
and then so that's that's really what it
is so there's companies out there like
that or you know they make a hundred
million dollars but they spend a hundred
million dollars yeah you know that so
they're a broke company technically yeah
you know so it's it's really interesting
in the business world there's so many
different ways when you're talking about
profit - yeah there's not just it's just
so so many things yeah yeah and I think
I I didn't realize until I read the
couple of comments in a couple of
messages they want clarity on it it was
even some some people just being rude
yeah but I you know I'm not really I'm
not really mad about that it's more like
okay so this is what it is like there's
just basic business stuff that a lot of
people don't they don't yeah they don't
get and you know that's okay like I
understand it was just kind of like oh
[ __ ] so what people a lot of people who
don't own businesses they just see it
from the outside they go you have a
business you're ballin there's nothing
there's no knowledge in between that
they really know about so I mean just to
touch on that so with with go-for-broke
if I were to explain it even further
than the other podcast it was that what
I mean by the company grew so big that
we couldn't handle it is that number one
that we weren't properly staffed yeah
and number two because we weren't
properly staff a lot of our money went
into buying things for the company in
terms of services and goods that we
didn't know how to manage so we used all
our money on that and
but the number of what three or four I
forgot whatever but we just we only did
it ten percent of the time each of us
yeah and it's a learning experience now
everyone is going to know before they do
the actions and that's one of the dark
side of entrepreneurship yeah right like
like what they don't tell you is all the
failures like that that we have to go
through to learn our lesson and sure we
could have sat down and we could have
analyzed we could have learned we could
read and we could have talked to
consultants sure all those things there
there could have been 100% preventive
things that we could have gone through
but I always say the best lessons that
you learn is the the ones that you
learnt like go through yourselves yeah
and then that's just the that's just the
name of the game man like we got to do
it and that's what separates being a
business owner and and being an employee
like when you're an employee you can
make these mistakes but you still get
your paycheck unless you make a really
bad mistake and you get fired
yeah but regardless if you lose the
company money or not whatever you do
like like I was in shipping and if I
ship all the packages to the wrong
places
I'm not gonna get fired they're just
gonna say hey you made a mistake don't
do it next time yeah but the company
eats that cost yeah they lose money
because they got a now reship it to the
right place and all these things but
nothing happens to me I still get my
salary yeah so it's very different for
them because they don't understand how
that works
when you're a business owner you you
take the losses yeah so if if my
employee messes up and all of the
shipping goes wrong I don't make profit
that month because I'm fixing all of
their mistakes
I eat that risk but in return when it
does well five ten years from now I'm
the one that's gonna be you know yeah
doing way better but that's just a give
and take right like if you get a salary
now that's because you don't have to
take any other risks yeah so it's kind
of like a fair exchange but what ends up
happening is the lack of understanding
and education on both parts that it just
seems like oh man like if you're
business owner you got it [ __ ] good
yeah nah man
I like it because I get control over my
choices yeah but man it's just as hard
as working a job like I remember working
a job I mean there's just no matter what
you do it's not gonna be simple yeah and
it's hard yeah it is hard yeah I think
the when you're an employee too
sometimes what what gets lost in
translation like you were mentioning is
you get to play with daddy's money you
know daddy gives you money you get to
play and you're something sometimes like
people get ahead in themselves they go
oh I don't know why you run this company
this way I could do it so much better
you say that because it's not the money
that's playing in your file used to say
that all the time and I was like when I
start a business I'm not gonna do it
this way yeah and then I [ __ ] up oh
that's right this is my money than I'm
playing with you know it's different
yeah now you because before you were
gambling literally with somebody else's
change yeah and you're willing to make
those risks because you don't see the
adverse effects it has on you and your
lifestyle because you're still gonna
walk away with a paycheck mm-hmm you're
still gonna be okay with it but that's
not how the owner of the business looks
at it oh [ __ ] like if this [ __ ] up
this whole company can go down yeah and
I mean what it is what I love about
being a business owner though is the
learning experience it's just like a
non-stop journey of ups and downs and
like you don't know what's gonna happen
tomorrow so it's kind of like this
adventure because there's so much risk
involved it just makes everything so
exciting I actually like making mistakes
and like doing weird [ __ ] because from
that it makes life interesting yeah and
we definitely learned because in this
case and I guess one of the questions
that people are asking is like oh so did
go for broke failed no I will never say
go for Belial oh it did not ban it did
not fail it's just it did not fail how
how does three people who put 10% of
their time into a company run a
seven-figure company yeah how how do you
do that yeah I wait by the way one
person managing customer service exactly
oh yeah we think that was like tens of
thousands of orders and [ __ ] exactly so
how do we do this and there was no way
and if we kept this company going we
would have lost a lot more money and
that [ __ ] would have killed us sometimes
you got to know when to exit
yeah so that was smart guys we just
broke even right I mean that's that was
likely to fail it's like I got to learn
all of this I got so much experience I
know what to not do next time I know my
limits and I got to do it without paying
anything I broke even we broke even
I didn't lose money that's that's that's
winning in my book it's winning but I
also think you have to be a bit of an
optimist to be an entrepreneur yeah
because most people will see that as
failure and they'll be like why even do
that why put yourself through that me on
the other hand like I don't see life the
same way they do so I see it as life
that was awesome dude like us three we
created like this thing everyone got
shirts it was like awesome and we didn't
lose money and we learned so much from
it yeah and maybe there's got to tell
myself that so I don't feel bad about it
but at the same time I truly do believe
that and I feel like good about it yeah
it's it's entrepreneurship and happen
your destiny in your own hand is it's
not for everybody and I'm not saying
that it's better or worse I'm saying
just some people just aren't built for
it why it's like is it for you or not
that's all I'm saying cuz I if if I'm
just being completely honest I would
like to be able to have that mentality
where I could there are some people who
are so good at doing the same thing
every day
and they live in [ __ ] bliss and
that's the kind of life that I sometimes
Envy because if you like routine if you
like women I wish I would really like
routine cuz if I did then I wouldn't
have to waste my time trying to figure
out everything every day it's kind of
it's like I look at them like I have a
friend the guy's an engineer and the guy
just he's very happy working his
nine-to-five and been doing his hobbies
on the weekend yeah I want to do my
hobbies 24/7 yeah in here say me I want
to do my hobbies 24/7 yeah for sure and
that's the hard part right it's like
okay well if you're going to be in that
realm then you got to figure out how to
make these hobbies profitable mm-hmm and
live like that even when it fails you
got to take those losses and move on
from it and try again try again try
again and that's gonna be what you're
gonna be doing for the rest of your life
yeah I mean money is always good but I
got into this because of the lifestyle
yeah like it's like I gotta get creative
on how to maintain this lifestyle so I
could make this
are you talking to my friend and where
this is work this is worth talking to my
friend and entertaining people sharing
my thoughts like how can I make food
like work yeah you mean like in and some
people get into business for different
reasons they'll be like yeah just want
to make a [ __ ] ton of money I just want
to figure out things some people get in
for more like a holistic reason or like
a more community reason like I want to
change the world I want to help people
there's so many different reasons why
people get into business but I always
say like there's two things people
should all do is one do a start a
business I want everyone in the world to
just start a business and try it yeah
and and just experience it even if they
don't stick with it just to know what
it's like and to is serve people like
you and a restaurant yeah humbly I want
I want people everyone to experience
what it's like to be a server at a
restaurant yeah that [ __ ] will change
you man it's it's and don't even look at
it I say don't even look at like what we
do to as something people should be
envious of just know that we found our
lane and figure out what your lane is
yeah you know because a lot of the times
I hear people say this they go I could
do that too alright [ __ ] do with this
if you could do what we do what a
[ __ ] arrogant [ __ ] yeah you hear that
[ __ ] all the time it was like I could do
that
mmm Madhu be my [ __ ] guest those are
like the guys at the UFC fights that are
watching and they're like oh you don't
know what you're doing it's like really
dude like yeah go in the [ __ ] cage
yeah like you you be my [ __ ] guest
even people who do podcast right but I
could do a podcast you really [ __ ]
cut it though yeah and the reason why is
just you're just weren't built for it do
you think it's easy sitting here having
commerce it's like it's easy for us
because it's natural and we've done so
much stupid [ __ ] in our lives and [ __ ]
up so many times we have so many things
to talk about it's a skill though it's
just it's a skill to have you don't
think that I've brought like three or
four people here already to sit at this
table and have this conversation and
they could not do it yeah they couldn't
do it and I didn't understand why and
it's just because some people aren't
wired like that no they didn't just
didn't didn't build a skill set yeah cuz
I look at my best friend he's a
physician yes in his last year of his
residency and I I would never say to him
I could do what you do
I could [ __ ] cut out a heart and put
a new one in yeah
even dude even somebody like this dude
named James Cage white I love that is
his Asian dude that goes up he puts his
feelings and his hearts on the line
every day yeah hey dude
Tim just sent me a text to this fool he
posed a Twitter post it's a photo that
he set up so he put because you could
tell he posted his phone on a coffee cup
and then he set a timer up and he sits
there and he grabs his head like this
and you're crying pretending to cry yes
and say oh how come I came out finding
love so I can't do that I cannot be him
if I was him I die I would [ __ ] die
that's genius
that's genius word you gotta love that
[ __ ] yeah I respect his hustle I could
not draw those three-year-old drawings
and ask people if it's a good drawing
and put it on a t-shirt and selling as
merch I'm not would this [ __ ]
but that [ __ ] I'm gonna buy another one
soon yo shout-out the James Cage white
yo if you're ever in the States
you are allowed to come on genius brain
podcast yeah I want to pick your sad
brain I need I need him here dude I
[ __ ] I found out about him because of
Tim and this dude yeah and because I
already know how similar our sense of
humor is I already knew I was going to
love this guy I was on vine cuz he
started out he was on mine yeah he was
on vine I was on that [ __ ] vine 30
minute vine compilation' I watched it
like 20 times my Kuvera swaying I like
it I like so the back story to this guy
is this guy James Cage white he's in
China and he was trying to learn how to
speak English yeah through vine right it
was practicing English through vine so
he would put it up and he would get
feedback on it so he was just practicing
talking to somebody which is actually a
great way to learn how to speak English
yeah and it just blew up into something
else because he's so innocent yeah he
doesn't know how ridiculous yeah I like
a bow I got so [ __ ] mad when he when
he started saying banana right my man
he used to say but ladder but I'll
already good hey this empanada is very
cool very swag I like it
and then some people were cracking jokes
oh I'm saying yo you call a banana that
he never says banana anymore oh don't
break the [ __ ] joke dude let him say
Pollyanna my ladder
he's a Berliner I [ __ ] love that guy
dude all right I remember his like food
that he would always post it what I
loved about the dude is he is so [ __ ]
grateful oh yeah like he he's eating
like garbage slop like factory peasant
[ __ ] and then he's like beef he's very
delicious I like it and I was like it's
literally just like rice in water with a
little bit of pickles on the side and I
was like what the [ __ ] dude this guy is
so sad and then he's eating a banana or
like an apple like it's the it's like as
a dessert dude and then you would give
him $25 for his teeth I would which in
China is like [ __ ] like 60 bucks in a
heartbeat I would do it so he could have
bananas for life
dude I I genuinely liked that guy man
there are some people on the internet
that are so innocent [ __ ] a hitman
breaker of the eye I miss him too dude
he doesn't do anything anymore Innova
Roku nuovo Roku you came to one of my
shows man I love that guy shoutout to
nova Roku dude you know he got he got
hacked and all of his videos taken down
and all this war is that why he
disappeared yeah man and then he try to
come back and then it just didn't work
out you know Nova Rock who I love you
bro yeah I miss I miss Nova Roku yo you
gotta get we got to get that full-on
genius brain man love that guy I know
well anyways guys that's another pup man
we talked about a lot of [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
was it over an hour already
y'all know we actually had a specific
topic we forgot to get okay well next
time we'll talk about it next time this
was good yeah man so remember you can
check us out on iTunes Spotify casts box
any kind of audio platform we're gonna
be there make sure that you listen to us
give us a listen to if you're watching
this on YouTube once again leave
comments below about the stuff you want
us to talk about genius brain is a
podcast or just regular people talk
about regular [ __ ] about anything and
everything because everybody has
something to say we love you [ __ ]
dust them on a good [ __ ] yeah we'll see
you guys next time stay genius